c'est l'image avant et l'
image après du théâtre de Maripol que nous avons
évalué et nous avons catégorisé les dégâts
comme dommages graves
[Musique]
étrangère en
utilisant des images satellites pour euh pour avoir une
meilleure compréhension de la situation sur
le terrain Nous comparons avant et après
images pour pouvoir les comparer et
comprendre ce qui s'est passé entre les
différentes dates que regardez-vous
ici les différents points de couleur
représentent le niveau de dégâts de
chacun des bâtiments endommagés à Mariopul
à cette date donnée
dommages catastrophiques étrangers
[Musique  ]
en bas, il y a un graphique à barres que vous remarquerez
[Musique]
nos principales
responsabilités sont de nous assurer que nous
disposons d'informations disponibles sur les
sites et la situation dans laquelle ils se trouvent afin d'être
prêts pour la récupération
à l'étranger